he was an incredible lawyer as
most brilliant guy i ever met but he was
limited
i tried
i could have tried harder
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
talk about the ending of better call
saul and this video will absolutely
contain spoilers for the end of the
breaking bad universe if you haven't
watched the finale yet i imagine at some
point there was a meeting where peter
gould explained a vital piece of
information to his costume director i'm
gonna need you to find a suit that goes
so hard that it drips saul goodman even
when we see it in black and white after
all this is a man getting dressed for
his own funeral solgon is the rare tv
series finale where i got everything
that i wanted and then some it managed
to give me more than what i was willing
to expect for fear of being disappointed
i may not have necessarily been hoping
to see gene turn so hard into being saul
but what i thought was brilliant in the
way this was put together was that the
writers led me on a journey where
because of what i know about the
characters i could more or less
anticipate each step and it all felt
right once again they managed to make it
exciting even though ultimately the
characters do what we expect them to do
and to be fair it's a lot more cerebral
than what i imagined some people were
wanting so i guess i could see how it
might not land for some but i'll come
back around to my thoughts about why it
worked after i recapped what happened
spoiler alert because jimmy didn't get
away with it and still found redemption
from the only person that matters to him
episode 13 opens with the first of three
flashbacks which in his interview with
alan seppenwall peter gould compared to
a christmas carol in the episode we
watched gene become saul and he's
visited by three ghosts the first is
mike ehrman trout which happens during
their trek through the desert back in
episode 508 bagman i guess if we really
wanted to put this in context for the
timeline since he still has his urine in
the davison main bottle when he finally
gets phone service this would have to be
after they make contact and no help is
on the way jimmy brings up the idea of
keeping the seven million dollars and
when mike explains why that would be a
bad idea he lays out his plan take the
first 6 million and build a time machine
that leads to the question of where's
the first place you'd go mike says back
to december 8 2001 which i presume is
the night he killed his son maddy's
murderers based on the timing of things
but he quickly updates that to the first
day he took a bribe and became a crooked
cop what's more important than his
answer is that he's being honest which
jimmy shows is something he's incapable
of when he talks about going back to
invest the rest of his money this is
before howard died and before kim left
him and so before he ever decided to go
full saul to try to relieve his pain so
we know his answer is bs this lack of
honesty will continue through the second
flashback where we go back to ed the
disappears basement during the events of
the penultimate episode of breaking bad
before saul was carried off to become
gene in omaha and walt was stashed away
in new hampshire they spent some time
together and saul brought up the time
machine question again walt being the
arrogant prick he is dismisses it as a
meaningless question because that kind
of time travel is impossible as it would
violate the second law of thermodynamics
this takes us a step closer to what the
whole thing is about when walt calls it
what it is saul is asking him about his
regrets mr white almost gets there when
he mentions gray matter but quickly
shifts the blame away from himself by
saying that his partners were artfully
maneuvering him into making his decision
saul still can't come up with anything
real so he brings up a slip and fall
that still gives him pain and to that
walt says so you were always like this
this sounds a lot like the third ghost
his brother chuck and is something that
would later be echoed by howard hamlin
right before he died and i do think this
is crucial to what they're trying to say
with this story so i will definitely
come back to it at the end
before we get into that this finale is
about change and before that can happen
jimmy slash saul
jean has to make a choice to get us
there the present day timeline picks up
right where episode 12 left off we saw a
glimpse of jimmy when he didn't stop
marion from pushing the button on her
life alert but now he's fully gene in
survival mode trying to escape on his
way out in her last dramatic
contribution marion is able to get his
license plate number which means it
doesn't take the police long to track
him down there's a short chase where it
seems like he might have a chance to get
away i mean he still has those diamonds
and ed's number right yes but no his
escape ends in a dumpster which is a
nice reference to the beginning of the
sandpiper case back in season 1. in case
you weren't sure where his head was it
can be kind of confusing his first call
is to cinnabon to tell them they'll be
needing a new manager after that he sort
of falls apart in the holding cell and
at his lowest point looks up to see my
lawyer will ream you as carved on the
wall he starts to laugh and in this
instant becomes saul goodman in the
script for the episode peter gould wrote
that as a fugitive he was playing a game
he didn't know but now that he's in the
system his system he's like cal l waking
up under a yellow sun in this place he
has super powers and we see him get
right down to the business of putting
those to use he calls bill oakley who
francesca told him had switched sides to
become a defense lawyer and he sets out
to get himself a deal on the way to meet
with the lawyers he sees marie schrader
and uses her as a prop to show them what
they're up against after listening to a
heartfelt monologue about losing her
husband and what she'd like to see
happen to saul he responds in kind with
a story about how he got dragged into
working with walter white he mentions
being taken to the desert and having a
gun pointed at his head and how that
scared him into doing everything he did
it's the kind of performance we've seen
before and he basically looks sincere no
one in the room believes this to be true
and the prosecutor doesn't think a jury
will either but that's not what's
important as saul points out all he
needs is one and that reality is enough
to bring them to the table he gets them
to agree to a really generous deal where
he'll serve seven years at the prison of
his choice it's all at full throttle and
while seven years is not nothing this
would pretty much go down as a legendary
win given the circumstances it almost
ends there but when he pushes for a pint
of blue bell mint chocolate chip ice
cream in exchange for information about
howard hamlin's death he learns about
kim going back to albuquerque to file
her affidavit with the d.a while that
steals his thunder as far as the mint
chocolate chip is concerned it gets
worse when bill tells him on the flight
back that even though there are no
witnesses and the d.a probably won't do
anything with it she also went to
confess to cheryl in person which means
she'll be able to bring a civil suit
against her we see that this gives saul
an idea but it's not at all clear what
his angle is he tells bill to tell the
prosecution that he has more information
about howard this is somewhat confusing
because as bill points out anything he
tells them might be bad for kim plus we
know that kim isn't looking for him to
save her but at this point we have to
sort of give it to him that he knows
better than us
after the end of the last episode i was
hoping that kim's breakdown on her way
out of albuquerque would mark the end of
the indecisive life she was leading in
florida we take a brief trip there to
see that it is starting to happen but
that it's going slow it's not jimmy
turning into saul or kim waking up in
the morning and snapping back to be her
old self in a scene at lunch with her
co-workers at palm coast she still
struggles to offer an opinion but later
we see her go to the local legal aid
office and volunteer it's a step in the
right direction and i loved how the
woman is so busy that she doesn't offer
much in the way of her having to make a
decision she just tells her to answer
the phone and we see how she lights up
and rises to the challenge right away
unfortunately any newfound piece she
achieved from this is dashed away when
she gets a call from ada eriksen she
tells her that saul's in custody and
that he's giving testimony that affects
her personally cut to saul goodman being
led into the courtroom with that
sharkskin suit i mentioned at the
beginning of the video we see that his
plan worked because kim is there and as
he derails his deal by telling the truth
we start to understand what he was
trying to do he tells the court that he
lied about her involvement in howard's
murder just because he wanted her to be
there to hear what he had to say he
started off with the same story he told
marie about being afraid of walt but
admits that it didn't last long he saw
an opportunity and did everything he
could to help walt build his empire we
know that all of this came from his
coping mechanism that he put into place
after she left and there's a moment
after bill hilariously tries to withdraw
from the case where he looks back to see
that kim is certainly watching but he
can tell he hasn't quite won her over
yet which at this point is clearly all
he's trying to do he brings up howard
and by now saul is gone he mentions that
kim had the guts to leave town and to
start over but he was the one who ran
away now that he's really looking at the
truth he moves on to admit that he got
chuck's insurance cancelled because he
saw a chance to hurt him and that he'll
have to live with the fact that he went
on to commit suicide and while this is
all coming from a person who we know
would say just about anything if it
would help him the fact that it doesn't
hear shows us that he's telling the
truth there are some visual clues to
enforce it as well when he mentions
chuck it cuts to a wide shot where we
can see the exit sign a lot chicanery
and hear the electric hum and there's a
shot of kim where she's framed like
she's in the crosshairs from the railing
in the courtroom it's also in the
performance and in the way he says the
name's mcgill i'm james mcgill but where
it really counts for him and for
everyone who fell in love with the
characters on this show where it really
counts is that kim believes him he looks
back at her one last time and when he
doesn't see the response right away he
drops his eyes but when he looks back up
ray seahorn does the most subtle bit of
facial acting where she doesn't really
do a look but the tension in her face
sort of eases up just enough to where
you see that it got through to her and
in case you didn't pick up on that it's
made explicit when he gets called for a
meeting with his lawyer i completely
expected this to beak him through the
long drawn out reveal but thought that
it meant that she'd been reinstated and
was moving on and practicing law again
in reality she just used her new mexico
bar card that doesn't have an expiration
date and boy was i glad that she did and
a beautiful callback to the first scene
they had together back in season one she
pulls out a cigarette and they share it
up against the wall her hands are
shaking as she tries to light it and
when he helps her steady them you see
that the flame and then the cherry on
the cigarette is in color it ain't much
but it's theirs and it's a spark that
comes from that thing that they share
you learn that instead of seven years he
ends up doing 86 for telling the truth
so even though he mentions good behavior
it seems safe to say that he'll never
get out of there this is a fictional
prison as far as i can tell so it's not
even clear if she'll come back to visit
this could be the only time they see
each other but again that's not what's
important here as kim walks out and
fights off tears she gets one more look
at jimmy in the yard and it's clear that
no matter what happens it was enough for
him to have just one more moment with
her in the closing shot he gives her the
finger guns and this time it's a sign
that saul's gone when she turns again
before he's out of sight you know that
she knows that he didn't do it to get
out of trouble or to win her over but to
set himself free it ain't much but given
what he's done it's also kind of
everything so in the end he didn't get
away with it he didn't even get what
walt or nacho did a chance to go out on
his own terms in the first half of this
show i thought the tragedy was that
jimmy a character who at his core was
always looking to be liked by everyone
and to be loved ultimately was looking
in a place where he could never get it
his brother chuck a complicated
character who was broken in different
ways to the point of not being able to
give it to him for the way things played
out it was more about him not being able
to find himself as all these things were
happening chuck's death the ordeal in
the desert lalo howard's death losing
kim and the entirety of his time with
walter white he may have brought most of
this on himself but these things ended
up defining him and his not being able
to move past them each thing sent him
further away from the good that was in
there and each made it harder to change
what i really liked about this is that
his most self-destructive period came
after kim made the hard but sensible
decision to leave after howard's death
so it's fitting that when he finally
comes around it's after he finds out
that she came clean to try to make that
right no one is saving anyone but the
thing that they share that connection
means enough to get jimmy to start the
process of changing it smashes chuck's
idea that jimmy was born that way and
that it was pointless for him to try to
be something different it also shows
that he's not the same type of character
as walter with him i always believed
that getting cancer was the thing that
allowed him to become what was always
under the surface he was motivated to
get respect and fear he thought he
deserved and was being denied in his
life and heisenberg was the realization
of that jimmy came off as more
complicated because after you met him
you started to wonder if the saul
persona you already knew might all just
be an act it turned out to be something
else something more self-destructive but
it wasn't terminal like walt's cancer
jimmy under the surface just wanted to
be loved and through his time with kim
learned what that could be because
that's the thing none of us have time
machines and as jimmy found out none of
us can run from our past forever we can
just go forward trying to make better
decisions and make the ones that the
people we care about would appreciate
jimmy only earned one smoke in one long
last look but it's worlds better than
anything saul goodman ever was a part of
i don't think it's a traditionally happy
ending but it could have been a lot
worse especially given how many people
die in this universe for jimmy being in
jail might not be the end of the world i
think you get a sense of that here if i
could have left one thing out of this
maybe it would be that bus ride chant
which was a little bit much but either
way you can imagine that he'd be able to
handle himself in there nothing about
what he did would appear to help kim's
situation with cheryl's civil suit but i
suppose she would feel that it's a just
punishment also jimmy could have really
wasted the opportunity if he tried to
solve that problem for her they both
paid the price for their mistakes to
some extent they both got there by their
own means and by finally taking some
responsibility and looking at the part
he played in the pain he carried around
he gets to be jimmy again
and speaking of chuck when jimmy was
doing his thing in court right after he
said his brother was a brilliant lawyer
he added that he was limited it seemed
like a really strange choice of words at
the time but it ties in really
wonderfully with the final ghost of
christmas past flashback in that we see
them in what appears to be the time
right before season 1 started did you
ground yourself it's like music to the
ears and there are about a thousand
references packed into this short
interaction but what stands out the most
is that at least in this case chuck is
the one that would like jimmy to stay so
they can talk as isolated as he was you
never got the sense that he was lonely
and i suppose neither did jimmy they go
back and forth and you see a warmer side
of chuck even though there's the sense
that he might be trying to talk him out
of practicing law to balance things out
it doesn't re-contextualize their
relationship but it is a reminder that
chuck did care for his brother in that
limited way that jimmy mentioned it
wasn't what he wanted but there was
something there and it's here that we
see the copy of the time machine by h.g
wells that popped up in the season 6
premiere in saul's mansion and again in
jimmy's room in episode 2. my initial
interpretation was that this meant that
this was jimmy's answer to the time
machine question maybe he would come
back and have this conversation with his
brother rather than rushing off to try
to impress him by being something he
thought he had no business being and in
the end it turns out he was pretty good
at that his being leaned back in his
chair as he listened to his deal put
that on full display it was glorious but
it wasn't everything and i think that is
a great place to leave things so let me
know in the comments what you thought
about the ending of better call saul and
how it worked as the ending of the
breaking bad universe there's a ton of
references and things i had to cut out
because there was so much going on that
i really wanted to focus on this change
that jimmy was going through as heavy as
it was it managed to throw in some great
laughs i cracked up when bill tried to
quit the case and when walt told saul to
stay in his lane it really is the end
and the callbacks and references really
made it feel that way the impact that
common items like the wayfarer headrest
on the airplane or when walt takes a
second to look at the watch that jesse
gave him for his birthday i'm gonna miss
seeing things like that pop up and the
writing and the acting and everything i
mean last week was sort of ray seahorn
showcase and this week was all about bob
odenkirk of course everyone involved did
a terrific job but i have to point out
how skillfully he went through this
episode changing from one of the
characters to the other that all exist
inside this same person there's just
nothing else like it and i could go on
forever but i won't i want to thank you
all for watching this season with me you
all helped to make it a blast please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon